on everybody it's warren welcome back to
the cosmic wonder and i just got back to
my hotel from attending the eternals
worldwide red carpet premiere it was
actually blue carpet which i i thought
was really cool actually it fit with the
theme of the eternals but
i did an initial reaction right away
walking out of the theater with eric
boss from new rockstars and uh greg alba
john uh get jaby you guys have seen him
for mama's geeky all these awesome
people go subscribe to them now they're
all great and eternals was
was so
beautifully different
than
i think
marvel has done before it's very
different it doesn't so much feel like a
marvel movie which i actually kind of
enjoyed now
i've heard just walking out
of the theater
hearing everybody's opinions about it
there are so many mixed opinions about
this and i'm just going to give you the
honest truth about how i feel about the
movie i don't think it was the greatest
marvel movie but i i truly truly
really like this movie
a lot i actually really love the
storytelling i actually really love the
cinematography i think it was a
beautiful
movie like i
i really think
this movie is beautiful
in a lot of different ways and i've
heard some people talk about how they
they actually don't think it was that
emotional but i actually felt a lot of
emotion in it and i thought there was a
lot of really good emotional parts in it
and um
it's interesting it's just such an
interesting movie there are two post
credits scenes which we'll like briefly
talk about this isn't a review i can't
do a review yet this is just a social
uh media reaction is what disney says we
can do so i'm not really going to dive
in detail but i am going to tell you
just my initial thoughts
and i can't express
how much i thought this movie was
beautiful
and this is interesting to me because i
thought chung chi was beautiful
i will say i did like shang chi more
than the eternals but
i still love the eternals i still love
this movie um
and really i they're two very different
movies and really the eternals is really
different
than any other movie that marvel has
done and i actually think that's a
really good thing i actually think
that's a good sign
that marvel's not going to continue to
do the same thing over and over again
which in one hand we do really love
marvel right we love marvel we love
what they do
but eventually it might i'm going to say
for sure because you know their movies
are awesome but eventually it might kind
of get repetitive might get boring but
these are like completely new characters
i think there are a lot of twists in the
movie that a lot of people kind of
didn't see coming maybe some of you did
um i was right about things i was wrong
about things um the post-credit scenes
are not what i thought they would be i
guess one is what i thought it would be
but not none i really talked about um
that much
so one i was like
i was like whoa
i was it was really cool um i was
sitting next to john humphrey
of the real rejects and mama's geeky
tessa
and we were like freaking out and i
think at one point tommy and tess were
like grabbing each other's hands in the
post credits you're like no it's this no
it's this no it's this no it's this and
it was like i was like ah
and uh it was cool it was cool um
and wow just the celestials were just
i can't express how cool they were it
was really okay this is an important
marvel movie it's heavy like
it's a heavy movie it's dense that's
that's a word that a lot of people have
been using that this movie is dense
because it's almost like
this is gonna sound weird because this
happens a lot but it's almost like
watching a book
like it's long it's over two and a half
hours long it's a long movie but it
didn't feel like it
it it didn't feel like it at all to me
at least i noticed some people they were
like yeah like i wanted to move a little
bit faster
but to me i thought it was perfect i i
thought they took the proper amount of
time on to do things like i didn't feel
like i was bored
like some people said because i didn't
go going expecting a lot of action
but there is there there's i will say
this
some of the coolest scenes that i saw
fighting came from makari
and i wasn't expecting it like really
like
or her ability is she's super fast right
there were some crazy cool scenes with
her fighting with her
using her speed i mean we've seen some
in the trailers right where her and king
go he like shoes and she's like checking
him king goes hilarious by the way he's
he's awesome camille nanjiani did a
fantastic job because he
he cracked me up i actually i you know i
really like the characters now that i
sit here thinking about it and i've
tried to gather my thoughts just a
little bit
to give you guys like a truthful honest
reaction um i liked all the characters
um some people said they felt a
disconnect to the character some people
said that it they didn't care about some
of the characters
but i truly i truly did enjoy the
characters i mean they're all very
different in their different ways
obviously but i mean there's 10 of them
right there's a lot of characters then
you have dane whitman as well who's not
eternal um but
he's in the movie like
you know sporadically right he's not
he's not an eternal right but his parts
are really fantastic i mean
it's kit harrington what you know
obviously you would expect that of him
he's fantastic
um
there was good chemistry between all of
the eternals which i really enjoyed i
loved watching them like as i sat there
i was just like this is really cool and
it honestly felt like
just the actors talking to each other
almost and um maybe some people might
not like that i did
um
there were a lot of things i enjoyed
about the movie this isn't so much of a
again it's not a traditional marvel
movie but it's not so much as like okay
we're gonna really really build up to
like
this one big thing and then it's gonna
happen and then like it's not a typical
like climax
um it's a lot of world building
a lot of character building eventually
they do have that part obviously um and
it's all just visually
phenomenal at least i thought so again
greg gable from the real rejects
he didn't like it that much
um and he stated his reasons why you can
go watch this video but i i disagree
with him and actually john disagreed
with him as well um i thought it looked
just
fantastic i
like i can't tell you how many times i
went whoa
that's cool like literally i would go
whoa that's cool
and i think a lot of people are going to
go in
at least looking at some of these scenes
and saying wow that's actually pretty
freaking cool like that looks visually
fantastic i don't think it's going to be
a movie for everybody just perfectly
honest um
i personally truly did enjoy this movie
i would even go as far as to say that i
love this movie um
it isn't like in my top five um it
probably would make my top ten
i would probably
give it it's not this isn't a review
right and i'll go into all that later
when the embargo lifts and i'll you know
talk about specifically why things uh i
like rate things a certain way but i
would probably give this like a seven
out of ten
whereas shangchi i gave like a nine
point five out of ten um just because of
some of the character arc chongqing
wanted more of so like that's like i'll
probably give like chiang chi like a 9.7
out of 10. um and internals like a seven
out of ten i think just
the storytelling was fantastic
chloe sao um
she's
fantastic i think the direction was
exactly what she wanted it
to be um
and i think they captured it really
really well
and i love seeing people like angelina
jolie in the mcu people like salma hayek
and the mcu
and the experience of going to this red
carpet event was like really really cool
i got to meet taikawatiti that was
actually kind of funny we were like just
walking and all of a sudden people
yelled like taika and i just kind of
turned around i'm like oh my gosh that's
taikawatiti standing right behind me and
then i just turned i'm like hi taika my
name is warren like really really big
fan of yours um i talked to him a little
bit about free guy and he literally
looked at me and went up a turkey boiled
turkey off albuquerque boiled turkey and
i was like no way you just said that to
me from free guy and then i told him
jojo rabbit is like one of my favorite
movies and i expressed how awesome he
was in that and then obviously i told
him i was super excited for a thor love
and thunder and he's like oh if i ever
get to finish filming it because you
know the delays and everything like that
i'm like yeah the delays today it was
such a bummer man he's like yeah then i
asked if i could grab a quick pick with
them which it did um
and i i posted a lot of this to my
instagram uh and i'm gonna be posting a
lot more to my personal instagram and to
my main instagram so you can find me uh
cosmic warren
and at cosmic wonder official if you
want to check out some of the photos uh
and videos that i took last night um
and and really this
this movie is sweet i
i had a really great experience watching
the movie i was entertained the entire
time i like the stories of each of the
characters because they're not always
all together in the film and they
concentrate on like different stories
and i think that's really really cool um
and again the post-credits scenes are
just wow um it's not like venom where
it's like everyone was talking about the
post-christian post-christian
post-credits scene like the movie
is a there's a lot of talk about the
movie but then the post-credits scene is
like that's also like a lot to talk
about um so it was just super cool uh
finally met eric voss in person uh met a
lot of cool people in person and it was
just an overall great experience but the
movie itself i think a lot of people are
really gonna like this movie a lot of
people are gonna really love this movie
and a lot of people are probably gonna
think that it's so so uh i'm gonna go on
the side of i actually really loved it
um
probably giving that like seven
seven and a half out of ten i thought it
was i thought it was beautiful i can't
stress that enough like the
cinematography the relationship between
the characters some of the scenes i
thought it was touching and beautiful so
it comes out in like two and a half
weeks so i'm very curious to hear what
everybody has to say about it how
everybody feels about the eternals when
it finally comes up let me know what
you're most excited for in the comments
down below this is one of those times
where it's just like i can't really say
much like
because i know stuff now but anyways i
want to express how grateful i am for
all of you for supporting me to be able
to go to these premieres um and give you
my thoughts on them ahead of times dream
come true i love you all and uh if you
wanna
watch more videos about marvel uh
subscribe
i'll catch you guys next time woof
you